what
[Applause]
[Music]
pilot the [ __ ] Bombardier
[ __ ] it's Thursday the 22nd I'll
[ __ ] December a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive as you
could tell the sunshine on my [ __ ]
face it I vitamin B and I'm ready to go
we got nothing on me I'm the man of many
refills at the Paris guy walk up my man
Ryan in Ventura
give me some shitty GRU [ __ ]
tremendous let me tell you [ __ ]
something I'm gonna reach out to the
people came to the show last night at
the Hong Kong [ __ ] in and tore
that place up you guys a tremendous man
thank you very much happy holidays and
that's it and that's that the two
podcasts for the we clear up I got a
spot at the [ __ ] comedy store tonight
I got jujitsu I went this morning I
gotta go tomorrow I got [ __ ] to doing
people to see that we have the [ __ ]
holidays tonight I'm gonna take the baby
to see some [ __ ] light some land you
know how we do it but before all this
happens
we gotta get together and get our heads
together a little afternoon [ __ ]
delight that's all afternoon dee-lite
whatever we're over here sparkly [ __ ]
you know anyway I got not much to say
I'm just happy I touched base with you
[ __ ] this Apple oh you think I
ever forget about your [ __ ]
don't forget the specialist on C so cold
Joey you get two months for free if you
haven't seen it do me a [ __ ] favor
have you have seen it will you only to
tell you I did what I could I'm not the
funniest [ __ ] guy in the world I just
[ __ ] never gave up on it but anyway
I'm stumped
let's smoke a few balls chitchat I mean
I've told you once I told you a million
times this is the best [ __ ]
part about that when we get together
like gentlemen and we [ __ ] make it
happen okay I know there's some women
there sparking - you know I love your
[ __ ] freaks with all my goddamn
bother but we don't forget to your dvrs
tonight do me the favor again the Comedy
Central this is not happy it's myself
Greg Fitzsimmons and Ali Siddiq it's
like a church [ __ ] reunion
smooches I can tell you all the stories
I want but the best thing I do is when I
come out here with you [ __ ]
then we get our party started together
like a family that's the most important
it's not about the jokes it's not about
the stupid [ __ ] to Lee or [ __ ] stars
of debt it's about us as family
coming out Hitler did you ever dream
that you could smoke with your uncle
Joey ready and there's nobody here this
moment look at my friend we have no
[ __ ] friends all right I got you
[ __ ] to catch the baby and the
wife and leave buddies in Vegas right
now
yes which casinos cuz he's getting beat
up at some [ __ ] value but that's what
he gets he wants to be joke gambler what
do you know
look at that between the smoke and the
Sun that apparently [ __ ] Sun Tan
Lotion you can [ __ ] dinner and that's
slope [ __ ] that's what [ __ ]
[Music]
but that's it this is what we do
battalion I'm a physicist I'm no psychic
I just smoke dope shout out right back
to Belfast you bad [ __ ] you
know I love you Irish [ __ ] stay
black and beautiful
I'm stoned I'm sore I'm not tired I tell
you that much we do a little writing and
you're ready for tonight and that's it
people we got two more three more
shopping
[ __ ] shoplifting days left do what
you gotta [ __ ] do you understand me
this time of the year it's sad for a lot
of people you know I've had some bad
[ __ ] Christmases but I'll tell you
what if you're going through a rough
Christmas right now brother it gets
better
you don't told you your uncle Joey
taught you trust long time you suck this
one and put a smile on your face walk
through it
think of the people that you mess or
whatever's going on in your life and
you're gonna be all right
just ever hass thanks [ __ ] to [ __ ]
of those holes I spent two Christmases
in prison you know what there was going
into it I was like you know what there's
gonna be the toughest Christmas Evan and
they were the best ones they were the
easiest one so I know a lot of people
going through hard times you know your
uncle Joey mother's just snap out of it
you ain't got time to bleed you know I'm
saying make the note see where your head
is at check it and move the [ __ ] on cuz
2017 is gonna be real I don't want you
to be a [ __ ] bother you know I'm
saying you think I'd do push-ups and go
to jujitsu because I wanna be Joe
monsters no I want to be around this
year with you [ __ ] doesn't gonna
make it happen together okay write your
goals do your push-ups and keep [ __ ]
showing up and eventually they have a
sucking dick all right they may not suck
your dick today but eventually they
gotta suck your dick and you got that
from your uncle Joey [ __ ] I don't
know about money
stay pure in your life
don't put them a Lucan on nobody there's
a [ __ ] think I give a [ __ ] half the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up but keep believing God
and next Christmas we'll be [ __ ]
tip-top Magoo whether your mom's missing
whether your wife left you whether your
kid jumped off a [ __ ] building they
get easier and easier I'm saying Joey
what are you [ __ ] dr. Phil dr. bill
when I was [ __ ] name is I smoked this
[ __ ] onion here let's do it
just like that I don't know about 420 I
don't know about 580 I know when it's
time to get down it's time to get down
[ __ ] waiting do we do one more
stony weed it feels like I got shot my
[ __ ] head Barris unbelievable I
smoked one more what do you think wait
what do you have to do it your [ __ ]
Lillee William Gord Stevie I need the
Simpsons I'm having a good time
look there's a [ __ ] I'm the uncle Joey I
don't come around too much and I'm
saying I come around on Saturdays
because this was a halfway house lets me
out this is what we got is what we got
to make the best of all right I got [ __ ]
to do and people [ __ ] see I'm saying
I'd love to sit here with you
[ __ ] all day and all night till
the Sun Goes Down just spark him like a
[ __ ] animal but I got [ __ ] to do and
do some [ __ ] work as always happy
Holidays to you and your family whether
you're [ __ ] Jewish brought a little
fun with the [ __ ] you want happy
holidays man make the best of it hug
your family real tight cuz you don't
know one that never [ __ ] disappear
enjoy yourself even if you having a bad
time let yourself have a good time on
Christmas saying the stupid songs along
to the mistletoe kiss your [ __ ] fat
ass and tomorrow you'll wake up the next
day you'll wake up feeling a lot [ __ ]
better okay the [ __ ] my token I see
my like smoking real food does next
thing you know I'm talking about sense
adders set the mental shift
anyway this is not happening a Comedy
Central don't forget the [ __ ] set
your DVR live from the guard the good me
will Gunkel [ __ ] joy misses you I
love you and stay black have a good
[ __ ] day and don't let them but don't
even think about letting these a lot of
fun to say something to you what
[Music]